[Musik]
das beste
die ehemalige opel gelände in bochum im
jahr 2020 in den 60er jahren begann hier
eine große euphorie 20.000 menschen
arbeiteten hier die opelaner wie sie
sich selber nannten und fertigten
350.000 autos
das ist davon geblieben ist das ein
symbol für das autoland in der krise
zwei zahlen sollen deutlich machen dass
es probleme gibt und dass die
tiefgreifend sind etwa beim außenhandel
die exporte mit deutschen autos sind
eingebrochen von 400.000 verkauften
fahrzeugen ins ausland im letzten jahr
pro monat auf 17.600 im april dieses
jahres
und wie wichtig ist der umsatz der
autoindustrie
er macht 22,1 prozent der gesamten
industrie in deutschland aus
noch arbeiten in deutschland fast eine
million menschen in der autoindustrie
autoindustrie bedeutet für deutschland
wohlstand
doch dieser steht in frage der wandel
ist schon jetzt spürbar hier in bochum
entsteht maßnahmepaket dienstleistung
wie sicher ist die zukunft der branche
die in deutschland ihre wurzeln hat
besonders betroffen ist der süden der
republik wie baden-württemberg x mon
amour ja und ich haben uns dort
umgeschaut wie sieht es in der wiege des
autos aus bei daimler oder wie hier bei
porsche welche enorme wirtschaftliche
bedeutung die automobilindustrie für den
standort deutschland hatte das sieht man
etwa auch an diesem automobil das ist
das erste elektroauto von 1898 das ist
noch entwickelt worden von ferdinand
porsche eine enorme transformation über
die über 120 jahre aber eine
transformation die jetzt im augenblick
eine besondere wirtschaftliche bedeutung
bekommt denn wir befinden uns an einer
schwelle zu einer neuen elektrifizierung
etwa zu neuen antrieben und damit auch
zu einem gewissen wirtschaftlichen
risiko für diese so wichtige
automobilindustrie
wie sieht das auto von morgen aus
welcher hersteller wird mit welchen
produkten überleben das ist nicht nur
eine frage der unternehmerischen vision
denn könig bleibt ja der kunde sagt uns
einer der ins silicon valley
ausgewandert ist
ende der 90er jahre oder wir haben den
audi auch bei anderen hier schon einiges
wir als verbraucher haben sie nicht
entsprechend gekauft sondern und da sage
ich auch wir alle fahren mittlerweile
diesen ganzen suvs und von daher wir
sind die mobilität nachfrage und angebot
die industrie verkauft solange das
produkt gut läuft das innovations-
dilemma der suv wird dann halt ein
elektrischer panzer und wenn die
nachfrage stockt ruft die industrie nach
staatsgeld bisher bedingung
los als regierungssicht würde ich sagen
so liebe leute das sind die
anforderungen wir wollen jetzt den
wettbewerb in zehn jahren werden kein
auto mehr in die stadt gelassen dass
mehr als 500 kilo wiegt und regenerative
energie sowie so und wir wollen auch
dass niemand mehr einen unfall erleidet
und ihr dürft euch jetzt die passende
lösung aussuchen
also entweder macht ihr das autonom oder
kleiner oder leichter oder mit rotem
blinklicht das dürft euch alles
aussuchen technologieneutral der kampf
ums auto wird weltweit ausgetragen der
größte markt ist china die beste
hardware kommt noch aus deutschland die
meisten ideen werden noch in kalifornien
geboren weil die technologie champions
hier beim thema fortbewegung keine
eingefahrenen gleise kennen selbst
fahrend vernetzt die nutzung geteilt
mehr mobilität aber weniger autos und
gar kein auto mehr im alten stil
es können sich firmen wie google sehr
leicht machen weil ihr geschäftsmodell
nicht unterbunden wird
aber für autohersteller ist eine
schwierige frage was passiert wenn wir
noch ein drittel der us hersteller heute
herstellen ist das gut oder schlecht und
ich glaube da müssen sich auch deutsche
firmen angehören ich glaube um das zu
überleben
längerfristig gesehen wird sich diese
änderungen geben und die die
innovativsten sind uns erstellten
bewegen können wenn das rennen gewinnen
sebastian ton hat das erste selbst
fahrende auto für google mitentwickelt
inzwischen lebt er mit seinem neuesten
produkt tatsächlich ab der rat des
erfinders immer quer denken kann man
einfach nicht frage stellen war muss
oder erfahrungen kann nicht fliegen und
schleicht sich die fragen der dumme
frage aber sollte sich stellen
vorher müssen die deutschen aber erst
fürs digitale elektrische zeitalter
flugfähige werden volkswagen kann sein
auto der zukunft id3 noch nicht
ausliefern wegen ungelöster software
probleme aber die schuld kann man ja
jetzt erst einmal corona zu schieben
professor dudenhöffer seit jahrzehnten
betrachten sie die entwicklung der
autoindustrie rund um die welt aber vor
allen dingen auch in deutschland an
welchem punkt stehen wir denn jetzt wir
haben eine transformation wir haben
softwareentwicklungen die viel wichtiger
werden als die technik im auto und wir
haben jetzt eine corona krise in welcher
phase befinden wir uns jetzt dass ich
glaube ist es wirklich der größte
umbruch den wir je in der
automobilindustrie in deutschland erlebt
haben gleichzeitig kommen wir aus
konjunkturell schwierigen zeiten da der
us-präsident trump zoll kriege gemacht
hat auf der zweiten seite ist es so dass
die elektromobilität die umsetzungen die
elektromobilität der läuft das sind
erhebliche investitionen und
veränderungen auch bei zulieferern und
autobauern
bei den beschäftigten in der
automobilindustrie zum dritten ist es so
dass die vorbereitungen für die
digitalisierung stück für stück gehen
dass er viel investiert werden muss und
zum vierten zu anderen kommt jetzt noch
diese corona krise die erheblich das
wirtschaftswachstum und die wohlfahrt in
wichtigen großen ländern in den keller
geschickt hat ist das was die korona
krise jetzt anbetrifft so eine art
brennglas für die ja enorme
veränderungen die sie beschreiben und
die möglicherweise auch eine krise ist
die sehr fundamental und existenziell
ist also corona wird die ganzen
veränderungen beschleunigen denn mit
corona sieht es so aus dass viele viel
schneller aus dem markt ausscheiden dass
ich viel viel schneller um orientieren
müssen als es früher gedacht war denn
das was der zeit verloren geht an
gewinnen die man bräuchte um in die
zukunft zu investieren das ist bei
vielen nicht ersetzbar diese hohen
verluste die jetzt entstehen werden
viele nicht tragen können
kritiker der deutschen autoindustrie
sagen ja seit jahren in der
batterietechnologie in der software aber
auch bei der veränderten mobilität ist
die deutsche autoindustrie einfach zu
langsam gewesen
auf diese veränderung zu reagieren man
hat immer sehr begeistert die
absatzzahlen in china sich angeguckt und
die enormen gewinne
aber vielleicht ist das jetzt der
falsche weg gewesen man war in einem
falschen geschäft drin
man hat geträumt von der zukunft mit dem
diesel mit dem plug in hybriden und
durch diese geld ist es total zerstört
von daher ist man überrascht worden man
hat die elektromobilität die voll
elektrischen autos nicht ernst genommen
in der vergangenheit vor drei vier fünf
jahren
man hat diese batterie geschichten nicht
ernst genommen und man hat eine struktur
in der deutschen autoindustrie die voll
und ganz auch bei den zulieferern auf
das geschäftsmodell von gestern
abgestimmt sind
[Musik]
tradition und moderne zusammenzubringen
das ist für einen hersteller wie porsche
durchaus eine herausforderung wie
steiner ist entwicklungschef von porsche
begrüße sie sehr herzlich
sie stehen ganz stolz vor einem teig an
das ist die zukunft ist tatsächlich die
zukunft das e-mobil ja ich bin überzeugt
mittel und langfristig die zukunft des e
mobil heute in der nächsten dekade wenn
man ganz sicherlich aber alle drei
antriebsformen in unseren autos haben
als die reinen verbrenner hochdrehende
sauger genauso wie thoma motoren die
plug in hybridantrieb oder überhaupt für
bremssysteme in summe und rein
elektrische fahrzeuge aber das
entwicklungspotenzial bei den
elektrischen fahrzeugen über die
nächsten jahre und vielleicht auch
jahrzehnte ist um vieles größer als beim
verbrennungsmotor der fall ich deswegen
sage ich mittel und langfristig ist es
da e antrieb in den nächsten jahren aber
wird alles parallel angeboten werden
aber genau das kann doch das problem
sein das ist eine transformation die
ungeheuer schwierig ist technologisch
weil sie beschreiben ja die
verschiedenen antriebs methoden das muss
ja auch beim kunden erst mal ankommen
der ist ja im zweifel auch verunsichert
und wir kommen jetzt auch noch aus einer
krise hoffentlich irgendwann raus was
ist denn da sozusagen zu befürchte dass
er hoch komplexe situation habe ich zwei
seiten die ein gesicht ist für uns als
entwicklung ist eine ganz spannende
sache aber eben sehr breit wir wollen
die verbrenner weiterentwickeln noch
detail verbesserungen machen effizienzen
holen emissions- stufen also abgas
weiterentwicklung machen wir wollen die
plug in hybrid antriebe und die hybride
stärker elektrifizieren etwas mehr
reichweite etwas mehr elektrische
performance und gleichzeitig eben so
viel wie möglich in die neue technologie
in die e mobilität investieren und auch
für die kunden
für die menschen die sich entscheiden
dürfen oder müssen was von fahrzeug was
vom konzept nehme ich es eine ganz
spannende zeit nicht für jeden ist heute
ein elektroauto die beste lösung wenn
sie nur ein fahrzeug im haushalt haben
dass sie täglich nutzen also von der st
eine reise in den urlaub vielleicht mit
der ganzen familie und für den täglichen
kurzstreckenverkehr dann ist ein reines
elektroauto je nachdem wo sie hinfahren
vielleicht noch nicht optimal weil die
ladeinfrastruktur sich erst entwickeln
muss was ist denn mit der
brennstoffzelle können sich das auch
vorstellen die
brennstoffzellentechnologie die
beobachten wir intensiv wir bei porsche
entwickeln selbst keine brennstoffzellen
ich glaube aber dass man für
langstrecken fahrzeuge für schwerere
fahrzeuge auch mit der
brennstoffzellentechnik eine
interessante technologie hat
[Musik]
an der ingenieurkunst der weltweit
gerühmten deutschen besteht kein zweifel
aber nun müssen strukturkrise
transformation und die folgen der korona
pandemie gleichzeitig bewältigt werden
staatliche subventionen wie 2008 mit der
abwrackprämie abgelehnt gilt allein löst
die probleme ohnehin nicht wir haben
jetzt eine situation wo der staat sehr
viel einfluss nehmen von der stadt auch
sehr viel geld ausgibt und wo man sich
fragt wo bleibt denn doch die reserve
eigentlich für die transformation
wir müssen tatsächlich nach der korona
krise vor allem den geist wieder in die
flasche kriegen und wir müssen mehr
leisten das war nicht das was wir nicht
an geld geben können das müssen wir im
grunde um an freiheit geben an
möglichkeit zu gestalten das heißt
weniger bürokratie
damit der wandel zu einem neuen system
die schneller vollziehen kann
[Musik]
nach den fetten jahrzehnten mit großen
gewinnen sind nun die autobauer gefragt
innovation und flexibilität die
stichworte in einem globalen wettlauf um
technische lösungen und marktanteile der
optimismus der autobauer
es werden corona wieder steil aufwärts
gehen ist verhalten
auch wenn die bänder wieder anlaufen es
ist ein signal der hoffnung dass daimler
senden will der autobauer öffnet höchst
selten seine tore für unsere kameras
normalerweise aber im moment ist eben
nichts normal und so dürfen wir filmen
wie mercedes in untertürkheim die
produktion von motoren wieder anwirft
vor allem für den chinesischen markt
denn in europa verkauft sich im moment
nichts
im grundsatz sind wir momentan zur
offene auslastung begründen von 50%
größenordnung wir laufen langsam nach
oben
und je nachdem wie der bedarf sich jetzt
auch wiederum entwickelt in richtung
unserer kunden sind in der lage ganz
schnell auch die stückzahl zu erhöhen
eine kurze verschnaufpause also von all
den hiobsbotschaften über 200.000
beschäftigte hängen ab im ländle von der
bereits vor corona schwächelnden
autoindustrie der zulieferer akku steht
stellvertretend für hunderte
mittelständler vor einem jahr
pumperlgesund dann kam die rezession die
holprige transformation und jetzt corona
plötzlich braucht keiner mehr maschinen
hat uns voll im wirtschaftlichen
abschwung erwischt
ich glaube nicht dass der staat alle
retten kann sondern es werden vermutlich
einige auf der strecke bleiben
manche die nichts dafür können man hätte
ja einfach in der vergangenheit schlecht
gewirtschaftet haben wie lange wird das
polster reichen diese frage stellt sich
ein paar kilometer weiter auch spediteur
rainer schmidt 300 transporte für
autohersteller fuhren seine leute vor
der krise jetzt sind es eine handvoll
und er hat keine ahnung wie hoch der
kredit ist den er beantragen soll wir
als unternehmer haben einmal die
möglichkeit ein kredit höhe festzulegen
ein kredit einmal zu beantragen der ist
sicherlich 1 es falsch ist entweder zu
hoch oder zu niedrig wir können
kostenfrei nicht
zurückgeben wenn wir zu viel beantragt
haben wir können nicht nach beantragen
wenn wir zu wenig beantragt haben das
ist unsere bisher in der wir alle
stecken wie viele unternehmen werden an
dieser krise scheitern
wirtschaftsforschung ist in diesen
zeiten mehr fischen im trüben
wir reden hier über zwei drei monate
dass die meisten unternehmen genug
rücklagen haben auch genug unterstützung
vom staat bekommen das zu verkraften
danach wird es für viele kritisch also
wir werden uns auf eine welle von
insolvenzen und auch ein anstieg der
arbeitslosigkeit einstellen müssen und
über allem hängt die große frage ob die
deutsche autoindustrie je wieder zum
vorkrisenniveau zurück findet
das daimler werk in untertürkheim in
stuttgart ein sinnbild der
automobilindustrie im südwesten der
republik nach 115 jahren werden hier
fahrzeuge hergestellt aber trotz des
schönen wetters hier in stuttgart
schwarze wolken auch über dem autobauer
mit dem silbernen stern
deutschlandweit arbeiten etwa 175.000
menschen bei daimler weltweit sind es
knapp 300.000 schon die jahresbilanz im
letzten jahr
sie hat schlechte zahlen vorher gesagt
denn der stellenabbau der wird bei
daimler auch in diesem jahr wieder ein
großes thema sind als es im saal noch
dunkel ist da fahren sie per video schon
ihre zukunftsvisionen ab visionen die
elektrisch sind die zeigen sollen
daimler hat mit dem umbruch begonnen weg
vom verbrenner hin zur neuen marschroute
electric forst das ist sicherlich die
größte investition größtes
investitionsvorhaben was wir jetzt haben
und da werden wir in den nächsten paar
jahren hier massiv hochform
milliardeninvestitionen in
elektromobilität werden nötig sein
in zeiten in denen daimler gleichzeitig
milliarden für die noch lange nicht
ausgestandene diesel krise bereithalten
muss beides diese rücklagen und hohe
investitionen in das elektrische fahren
sind auch hauptverantwortlich dafür dass
die daimler gewinne zuletzt massiv
eingebrochen sind
die finanziellen ergebnisse die wir
präsentieren für das jahr 2009 10 das
sieht nicht ergebnisse die wir für die
zukunft sehen wollen
das reicht nicht ein drastisches
sparprogramm soll nun helfen die kosten
zu senken
unter anderem werden arbeitsplätze
wegfallen gerüchten zufolge bis zu
15.000 außerdem wollen sie nicht
profitable fahrzeugmodelle aussortieren
ist es richtig dass man sich vielmehr
mit zukunftsthemen beschäftigt als man
es bisher getan hat in bezug auf e
mobilität läuft da etwa schon gefahr
einfach nicht mehr zur ersten liga zu
gehören ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
daimler in sachen elektromobilität
schneller sein würde
wir haben alle die sorge dass die co2
ziele nicht erreicht werden können das
hat neue strafzahlungen zur folge
nur mit mehr elektroautos werden co2
strafen von der eu zu verhindern sein
daimler muss also investieren und
gleichzeitig sparen ein schwieriger
spagat
der stellenabbau bei daimler längst kein
einzelfall
neben den autobauern klaren auch viele
zulieferer stellen zu streichen
der kahlschlag der trift landkreise und
kommunen deren wirtschaftliche stärke
jahrzehnte entscheidend vom auto abhänge
ein beispiel aus der oberpfalz
der autozulieferer continental in
blutigen in bayern
hier werden punkten für diesel und
benzin fahrzeuge hergestellt vergangenen
herbst kündigte der konzern an das werk
2024 zu schließen die zukunft der über
500 mitarbeiter ist ungewiss doch eine
erholungsphase für die mitarbeiter wegen
urlaub aber die stimmung schlecht ist
ganz klar die angst um ihre zukunft der
arbeitsplatz folge weg weinfelder weg
12.000 einwohner hat routing es ist eine
stadt die von der industrie lebt und
bürgermeister reichold hatte lange für
die ansiedlung von continental gekämpft
jetzt muss er wieder kämpfen damit die
folgen für seine stadt nicht zu
gravierend werden
das muss ja nicht die erste letzte firma
sein die die tore schließt sondern es
kommen ja mehr firmen die bei uns da
sein und für die automobilindustrie
produzieren die können ja auch noch
schließen sie produzieren für die
autoindustrie die firma stangl und
kulzer andrew ding hier werden bislang
die prototypen für das continental werk
hergestellt dieser auftrag entfällt
jetzt
man nicht so einfach weg aber alle
müssen sie nun orientieren
die arbeitsplätze verändern sich die
anforderungen an die arbeitnehmer
erinnern sich da müssen wir uns alle
stellen können jetzt sagen ok besetzen
habe das immer war der druck der wegfall
von continental ist den ruhigen schon
jetzt zu spüren bei geschäften und
gaststätten ein viertel der
übernachtungen vor allen in der pension
von stefan hecht künftig weg so wie
viele privat feiern der conti
mitarbeiter
das ist natürlich ein thema du musst
irgendwelches kompensieren weil die
vorhin da weckt einfach die hoster
nimmer und dann musste ich etwas neues
einfallen lassen dass die bude wieder
voll bringst einst galt dieser teil der
oberpfalz als bayerns armenhaus die
autoindustrie hat viel daran geändert
dass steht jetzt wieder infrage
eine herausforderung für die landkreise
für die kommunen in denen
automobilkonzerne aber autozulieferer
genauso ihre werke haben denn das ist
immer bedeutend für die arbeitsplätze
und wir sind jetzt in esslingen am
neckar eine etwa viertel stunde entfernt
von untertürkheim wo wir schon eben bei
daimler waren und auch hier spielt die
automobilindustrie eine große rolle und
die zulieferer welche sie spielt das
wollen wir etwas genauer wissen von
andreas zieger er es um bürgermeister in
esslingen herziger wir sind in ihrer
idyllischen stadt und haben gesehen
gerade in einem einspieler wie schwierig
die situation ist wenn ein zulieferer
wie continental das werk schließt wie
bedeutend ist die automobilindustrie
sind die zulieferer hier für sie und
ihre region mobilitäts geschichte das
entwickeln und produzieren von
automobilen ist teil der
erfolgsgeschichte des landes hier in der
region stuttgart sind 200.000 menschen
damit beschäftigt die es zu entwickeln
und aufzubauen das ist teil des
selbstverständnisses der region und
natürlich der einkommens- grundlage für
die familien und für die städte
jahrzehnte lang war das ja auch ein
verlässlicher partner für die städte
gerade was sie ansprechen die
arbeitsplätze die hier entstanden sind
durch diese betriebe wie blicken sie da
in die zukunft es gibt ein unternehmen
hier bei ihnen in der region eberspächer
angestammte in esslingen das jetzt 2022
ein werk schließt daimler baut ein neues
trotz allem ist das ja eine unsicherheit
auf diese sich einstellen müssen oder da
die wirtschaftlichen veränderungen
beschäftigen und seit mindestens 150
jahren die verlagerung von teilen der
produktion von eberspächer ist auch teil
einer globalisierten wirtschaft die
zentrale von eberspächer und mehr als
1000 arbeitsplätze bleiben hier auch
erhalten und in bezug auf die
automobilproduktion steht die ganze
region natürlich von besonderen
herausforderungen und die
automobilindustrie ist dominant für das
land zwar in der ganzen region stuttgart
das sind 2,6 millionen einwohner
deswegen ist mit 95.000 einwohnern teil
dieser region und es ist natürlich eine
herausforderung mit den fragen neuer
antriebs modelle die entwickelt werden
einer anderen mobilität auch einem
anderen kaufverhalten mieten statt
kaufen und natürlich den
herausforderungen welche antriebe sich
durchsetzen und wo produziert wird
ziemlich anstrengend und es beschäftigt
unternehmen und uns als städte in
besonderer weise diesem jahr ist die
gewerbesteuer um 50 prozent eingebrochen
für s leben heißt das statt 76 millionen
nur noch 38 millionen also das hat
auswirkungen auf finanzen
daseinsvorsorge und natürlich
lebensqualität in der region und in der
stadt sie sind seit 22 jahren ja
bürgermeister oberbürgermeister hiervon
eßling kennen die stadt natürlich auch
in gerade in diesem bezug ja mit ihrer
geschichte und auch vor allen dingen den
langen partnerschaften die mit der
industrie hier einhergehen und verwoben
sind was sagen die bürger
natürlich ist auch sorge in der
bürgerschaft festzustellen auch in der
politik ich setze aber nach wie vor auf
innovationskraft der region auf gut
ausgebildete mitarbeiter schafft auch
auf erfolgsprodukte die produkte sind ja
nach wie vor gut und dass es gelingt in
dieser transformation einer anderen
mobilität
andere antriebstechniken auch
wertschöpfung das heißt produktion und
damit arbeitsplätze hier in der rhön zu
sich herzlich ganz herzlichen dank für
das interview ja und welche aufgabe auf
die automobilindustrie zu kommt bei dem
transformativen wandel beispielsweise
bei den antriebstechniken das zeigt die
thematik der batterien und das e
antriebs jahre lang haben die deutschen
autokonzerne nach china geblickt und ein
stück weit den trend verschlafen jetzt
beginnen die deutschen autobauer mit der
aufholjagd
wer am ende die nase vorn hat das
entscheidet die batterie nicht nur in
der formel 1 auch auf der ganz normalen
straße läuft ein wettrennen um die
bessere elektro power deutschlands
autoindustrie will mehr als 40
milliarden euro in den nächsten jahren
investieren
und tatsächlich sie muss jetzt
ordentlich gas geben finden
marktbeobachter weil immobilität spiele
deutschen noch eine viel kleinere rolle
als im traditionellen geschäft da waren
sie wirklich dominant da waren sie
praktisch der die das land nummer 1 in
der welt da haben sie die praktisch den
hochwertigen den markt für hochwertige
autos total dominiert und diese rolle
haben sie bei ihrer autos absoluten auch
nicht da sind sie sogar immer noch eher
nachzügler sind asiaten weiter und da
ist auch beispielsweise eine tesla
weiter vor allem bei der
batterietechnologie scheint deutschland
geradezu abgehängt den markt beherrschen
hersteller aus asien allen voran keine
sonic
es ist tatsächlich ein hohes risiko dass
das thema batteriezelle wo ja ein
großteil der wertschöpfung von
elektrofahrzeugen auch hineinläuft dass
das ein thema ist was nicht in
deutschland nicht in europa produziert
wird hier macht man sich abhängig von
ausländischen zulieferern aus china aus
korea und japan
die batterie ist immerhin das herzstück
eines e autos entscheidet über
leistungsfähigkeit und über den preis
tesla produziert deshalb seine akkus
gemeinsam mit panasonic die california
kommen so auch an das batterie know how
in deutschland wird darüber bislang nur
diskutiert der verbrennungsmotor wird
wird sterben höchstwahrscheinlich der
elektromotor ist jetzt nichts besonderes
da könnte man jetzt sagen der batterie
stets steckt sozusagen der schlüssel der
zukunft aber wenn man sich da wir uns
denn überhaupt nicht erschließt ist man
schon in gewisser weise außen vor
das soll sich ändern um die dominanz
asiens zu brechen wird in deutschland
vor allem geforscht
neue methoden sollen ohne den knappen
rohstoff lithium auskommen bislang der
batterie standard dem helmholtz-institut
den ulm beispielsweise wird dann akkus
mit getrockneten äpfeln und anderen
nachwachsenden stoffen getüftelt kurios
keineswegs in zwei bis drei jahren will
man für die industrieproduktion bereit
sein
wir haben uns die frage gestellt wie
kann man denn da weiter machen das heißt
welche anderen naturstoffen bieten den
voraussetzungen die vielleicht sogar
noch besser als im und am ende sind wir
draufgekommen dass erdnuss schaden sogar
noch besser funktionieren als
kohlenstoffe auf apfel basis forschung
und forsche ideen es braucht aber noch
mehr energie
damit deutschland bei der e-mobilität
nicht auf der strecke bleibt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die automobilbauer die investieren
natürlich jetzt auch in das thema
batterien und alles was um die batterie
herum passiert da spielen natürlich auch
die zulieferer eine bedeutende rolle so
zum beispiel auch das unternehmen male
hat eigentlich mal angefangen mit den
themen kolben technik heute eine 100
jährige tradition und jetzt breit
aufgestellt wir haben die gelegenheit
mit martin berger zu sprechen er ist der
leiter für forschung und entwicklung wir
sind hier auf dem parkdeck ihres
unternehmens was genau hat es vor allen
dingen mit den innovationen auf sich die
sie zum beispiel beim thema
elektromobilität anfassen und bearbeiten
zum beispiel das thema laden das was sie
hier sehen auf diesem weg ist wenn sie
so wollen mal ist beitrag zum thema
ladeinfrastruktur
wir haben hier ein verteilt das
ladesystem mit in diesem falle 100
ladepunkte dieses system ist dafür
gedacht ihnen beim laden zu assistieren
wenn sie zeit haben ja das heißt wir
sprechen hier nicht von schnellladung so
wir sprechen von ladung sei es wenn sie
so wollen während sie zeit haben während
die parken in diesem fall hier während
sie arbeiten
das könnte aber auch an einem flughafen
installiert sein wir haben eine große
installation am flughafen in stuttgart
dieses system hilft ihnen einfach ihre
batterie voll zu bekommen wie ich sagte
wenn sie zeit haben wenn sie es wenn es
nicht darum geht schnell zu danken wie
eine autobahn zu bauen das ist jetzt zum
beispiel ein bereich in dem sie tätig
sind das thema elektromobilität fassen
sie auch aus ganz verschiedenen
perspektiven an ich hatte es jetzt
eingangs gesagt groß geworden bekannt
geworden sind sie über die kolben
technologie jetzt haben sie weltweit
heute 80.000 etwa mitarbeiter wie
stellen sie sich auch wenn es um die
thema und die thematiken des
transformationsländer geht der ja auch
die zulieferer neben der
automobilindustrie erfasst hat in den
letzten jahren male wie sie vielleicht
wissen verfolgt seit mehreren jahren
eine duale strategie was bedeutet das ja
also wir bewahren das mit dem wir groß
geworden sind wir verfolgen das weiter
wir entwickeln das weiterhin kriminell
bewegen uns aber in allen neuen feldern
ja wir sagen wir sind
antriebstechnologie offen
ja wir sind offen für einen wettbewerb
der antriebskonzepte das was das beste
ist für die umwelt für den verbraucher
und dir gehen
nicht erst seit kurzem sondern schon
seit längerer zeit auch in diesem neuen
felder reihen ein beispiel sehen sie
hier
andere beispiele sind in etwa
elektrotraktion oder auch
batteriesysteme ja also mal ist seit
längerem schon unterwegs unter diesem
dach der dualen strategie in der welt in
der wir groß geworden sind aber auch in
der neuen welt und der bogen dazwischen
ist genau das was man in der
transformation versteht
wundern sie sich nicht dass wir hier im
labor eine sicherheitsweste und
schutzbrillen tragen müssen herberger
wir sind hier an einem prüfstand für
elektromotoren was genau erforschen sich
hier an diesem prüfstand geht es konkret
um die nächste oder übernächste
generation von elektromotoren für die
interaktion also für den vortrieb eines
fahrzeugs ganz konkret erproben wir hier
motoren technologien die den
wirkungsgrad noch mal einen schritt
erhöhen und gleichzeitig habe ich schon
mal für einen kosten nicht allzu viel da
zu spielen sondern vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen kostensenkend wirken
zentral ist aber jedes thema
wirkungsgrad einfach die maximale
ausbeute haus so antriebsart sie hatten
uns oben gerade schon erzählt wie
wichtig das thema auch elektromobilität
als eines der wirtschaftlichen felder
ihres unternehmens ist wenn sie so ein
bisschen nach vorne in die zukunft
gucken und wir uns das thema mobilität
ein bisschen komplexer angucken wie
glauben sie wird die mobilität der
zukunft aussehen und welchen beitrag
wollen sie auch als mittelständisches
großunternehmen kann man ja schon sagen
daran leisten die frage ist recht
komplexe eigentlich zu beantworten ja es
gibt nicht die antwort auf ihre frage
welche antriebsart sich durchsetzen wird
zumindest nicht auch heutiger sicht fakt
ist es werden co2 neutrale antriebe
seien ja wir als zulieferer der ersten
schicht sozusagen als tier one verfolgen
einen offenen wettbewerb oder stellen
uns einen offenen wettbewerb der
antriebsarten ja wir bemühen uns für
unsere kunden in jedem segment die
passenden produkte bereit zu halten für
das thema co2 neutrale mobilität sei es
dann aus die tools die in
verbrennungsmotoren zum einsatz kommen
bis hin zu reinen elektro mobilen oder
irgendwo dazwischen in der übrigen welt
oder gar hinter brennstoffzellentechnik
die anfängliche euphorie über das
elektroauto ist verflogen die batterien
sind teuer die reichweite ist gering und
es gibt viel zu wenig ladestationen
vielleicht kommt es ja auch ganz anders
etwa über den wasserstoffantrieb oder
synthetische treibstoffe vielleicht am
ende also ein mix wie sich die industrie
darauf einstellt das kann man im
augenblick noch nicht einschätzen
schwierig wird es auf jeden fall auf der
straße liegen elektroautos in der
umweltbilanz form
sie verursachen kein co2 fürs klima
entscheidend sind aber auch die
co2-emissionen bei der herstellung und
beim stromverbrauch umgerechneten gramm
pro kilometer entsteht bei der
produktion wartung und entsorgung eines
autos mehr co2 als bei einem diesel oder
benziner für die herstellung von lithium
ionen batterien braucht man viel energie
studien zufolge bis zu 200 kilogramm co2
pro kilowattstunde speicherkapazität
allerdings über den gesamten
lebenszyklus von durchschnittlich zwölf
jahren verursachen e-autos am wenigsten
co2 im vergleich mit dieseln und
benzinern 2025 verringert sich der co2
ausstoß der e autos weiter der grund der
dann höhere anteil erneuerbarer energien
beim feinstaub wert schneiden
elektrofahrzeuge am schlechtesten ab
feinstaub entsteht laut
bundesumweltministerium vor allem bei
der autoproduktion am meisten bei autos
weil sie aufwendiger herzustellen sind
bei stickoxiden sind die emissionen bei
autos dagegen am niedrigsten im nachteil
sind e-autos gegenüber verbrennen beim
rohstoff aufwand für e-autos wird etwa
lithium benötigt auch kohlenstoff kupfer
nickel mangan mögliche alternativen zum
elektroauto sind brennstoffzellen
fahrzeuge oder synthetische kraftstoffe
für verbrennungsmotoren
um diese kraftstoffe herzustellen ist
aber viel strom nötig 93 bis 103
kilowatt stunden auf 100 kilometern bei
einem e-auto 15 kilowattstunden
die investition in forschung und
entwicklung sind auch immer bedeutend
für die standorte wo beispielsweise
automobile entwickelt werden und das
spürt man auch hier an der universität
in stuttgart wo wir jetzt sind wenn man
hier seit 1935 beispielsweise an den
antriebstechniken forscht aber die frage
wie sich die autobauer auf die zukunft
und auf die verschiedenen
antriebstechniken einstellen dies noch
gar nicht endgültig beantwortet und so
bilden sie beispielsweise ihre azubis
auf allen antriebstechniken aus dass der
verbrennungsmotor die brennstoffzelle
oder eben das e-auto ein beispiel wie es
bmw zeigt auf den ersten blick haben sie
viel spaß
die mechatronik azubis bei bmw da werden
roboter programmiert autonom fahrende
modelle getestet und arbeitsgänge durch
brillen mit virtueller realität
simuliert soll dass man die möglichkeit
hat sich das so in den virtuellen raum
da mit den robotern zu arbeiten
gewissermaßen ein verklärter blick in
die zukunft doch so rosig sieht die gar
nicht aus das wissen auch die azubis
aktuelle müsse die haut industrie groß
im umbruch denkt dass die politik die
weichen stellen soll und muss damit
daran die autokonzerne da ja gefordert
werden vorerst werden sie noch lange
zeit klassisch an auspuffanlagen
schrauben und sich mit abgas problemen
herumschlagen müssen
umweltfaktoren auch immer mehr
politischen faktoren nehmen wir zum
beispiel die co2 grenzwerte die jetzt
mehr gekommen sind die immer strenger
werden immer stärker werden muss
natürlich ein richtiger schritt gehen in
die richtung immer weiter
elektromobilität
elektroautos gelten oft als lösung aller
probleme doch viele azubis und auch
ausbilder sehen sie erstaunlich kritisch
so weit ausgereift ist dass wir ihn
wirklich ganz über weite strecken hin
benutzen können ich glaube an die ganze
welt bewegt autos nutzt
funktioniert das auf dauer nicht für die
autokonzerne heißt das sie müssen
gleichzeitig an autonomen systemen an
benzin und diesel und an neuen
antriebsarten arbeiten das macht die
forschung aber auch die azubi ausbildung
richtig teuer
im moment gehen wir in alle richtungen
es wird sicherlich auch noch für einige
jahre dauern langfristig sehen wir die
zukunft in der elektromobilität die dann
im späteren zeitraum vielleicht durch
wasserstoff abgelöst wird wasserstoff
scheint hier bei bmw das zauberwort zu
sein
auch bemerkenswert viele azubis setzen
darauf dann hat manche azubi noch ein
ganz anderes problem die tollen
selbstfahrer systeme soll man unbedingt
auch abschalten können
ich denke aber dass dann gerade wenn man
immer mal das auto fahren ja genießen
will dass wir da auch sprechen mal
selber gas geben darf sie wollen die
lust am individuellen fahren behalten
arbeiten aber dennoch am vernetzten
computer gesteuerten verkehr der zukunft
auf die azubis warten noch viele
berufliche herausforderungen nicht nur
die automobilkonzerne die fragen sich
auf welche antriebstechniken sie ihre
auszubildenden ausbilden sondern auch
die universitäten wie beispielsweise die
universität stuttgart ii gibt es seit
1935 einen lehrstuhl für fahrzeug wesen
und heute ist er leiter des lehrstuhls
für fahrzeugtechnik andreas wagner wir
sind hier am fahrzeugdynamik prüfstand
herr wagner eine einrichtung die so
zweimal auf der welt gibt was hat das
hier auf sich was prüfen sie hier und
die forschen sie an dieser einrichtung
sie haben schon gesagt das war die erste
einrichtung dieser art bis heute die
einzige öffentliche zugängliche
einrichtung dieser art
die idee ist man hat eine unendlich
große fläche für ein fahrzeug zur
verfügung auf der man fahren kann extrem
manöver machen kann oder das fahrzeug
anregen kann über die straße über halten
überstellt
und damit kann man verschiedene sachen
machen mit dem fahrzeug zum beispiel in
richtung autonomes fahren gedacht sich
verschiedene extreme fälle corner cases
nennt man die anschauen und diese
analysieren wie wichtig ist so ein
standort auch für die universitäre
forschung sie haben etwa 450 studenten
die hier an ihrem institut studieren wie
sieht die forschung dort mit den
automobilkonzern gemeinsam aus ist
extrem wichtig so etwas hier zu haben
das eigentlich ist natürlich es ist sehr
attraktiv für die studenten man kann
ihnen sehr sehr moderne technologie
zeigen ihnen wirklich die zukunftsfelder
als sehr anschaulich beibringen
auf der anderen seite ist das ein
prüfstand wo man sehr intensiv mit der
industrie zusammenarbeiten können
was natürlich schöne netzwerk gebildet
aber auf der anderen seite auch in
diesem dreier verbund studenten
industrie universität tolle
möglichkeiten bietet wenn sie jetzt auch
mit ihrer erfahrung die sie mit sich
bringen aus der langen zeit die sie in
der automobilindustrie waren in die
zukunft gucken wie optimistisch die
pessimistisch sind sie wenn es um den
standort deutschland geht
ich glaube im moment haben wir die
situation wo sehr viel das zusammenkommt
wenn sie zurückgehen 2016 war die
sogenannte diese krise die bis heute
zumindest und der kommunikation sehr
stark nachwirkt die transformation sie
haben es schon angesprochen das
verändert sich sehr viel im fahrzeug ums
fahrzeug drumherum
corona kommt jetzt mit dazu wie lange
die folgen uns noch beschäftigen werden
das können wir heute gar nicht absehen
also da kommt sehr sehr viel zusammen im
moment ich blicke wirklich sehr
optimistisch in die zukunft auch wenn im
moment schwierige zeiten sind aber ich
glaube der deutsche wirtschafts standort
insbesondere im bereich von entwicklung
forschung und lehre hat seit jeher sehr
viel potenzial hat das auch weiterhin
und wenn man sich jetzt richtig
aufstellt und ich meine dass schon zu
erkennen dass die weichen jetzt richtig
gestellt gestellt werden glaube ich ist
das nach wie vor ein sehr attraktiver
standort transformation das ist das
stichwort der autoindustrie im jahr 2020
und transformation bedeutet nicht nur
eine änderung in technologischer
hinsicht sondern auch in ganz an
den bereichen auch bereiche die den
kunden direkt betreffen wir wollen uns
unterhalten mit einem experten der lange
in der deutschen autoindustrie
gearbeitet hat stephan grühsem begrüße
ich in münchen und von ihm will ich
wissen was ändert sich denn eigentlich
in der autoindustrie und auch für den
kunden er größer das autohaus so wie wir
es heute kennen wird sicherlich keine
zukunft mehr haben eher größer im
augenblick ist es ja so dass ich mir am
computer im zweifelsfall im internet die
farbe aussuchen von neuen auto
vielleicht auch ledersitze oder
stoffbezug und dann gehe ich doch am
ende in ein autohaus und kaufe das auto
dort wird sich das ändern
ich konnte zudem ist im wesentlichen
darauf auf die peripherie sie wissen ja
selber die beherrschende diskussionen
der letzten monate
man kann schon ein zwei jahre sagen war
natürlich die technologie die neuen
antriebsformen weil es etwas zu kurz
gekommen ist in meinen augen ist die
beschäftigung eben auch mit der
digitalisierung im kundensegment er da
wo die wahren revolutionen vor kunde
stattfinden im handel in der art und
weise wie automobilbranche den kunden
behandelt wie einfach er ist ihm acht
autos zu kaufen und das ist eine etwas
vernachlässigte bereiche weil natürlich
die technologische diskussion alles
überstrahlt stuttgart schlossplatz
wohlstand aber angst dass das ländle das
ruhrgebiet von morgen wird die
landesregierung in sorge ob ministerin
wie gefährlich ist denn diese situation
für einen laden für baden württemberg
also ich denke wir müssen immer die
chancen im blick haben wie sich auch auf
so einer krise für uns als land und für
unsere wirtschaft ergeben
wir haben natürlich im bereich unserer
leitindustrie automobil
eine schwierige situation zum einen eine
strukturkrise zum anderen ein eine
konjunkturkrise und zwar schon im jahr
2009 10 beginnt und jetzt durch die
korona krise noch mal verschärft jetzt
guckt man ja immer erst auf die
autoindustrie auf die großen unternehmen
vielleicht auch auf die großen
zulieferer aber das geht ja ganz weit
auch in die kommunen hinein nämlich zb
bei der gewerbesteuer die nicht mehr so
hoch ausfällt bis zu 50 prozent sagen
einzelne bürgermeister fehlen uns dann
statt ca die kommunen sind grundsätzlich
natürlich wichtige player auch bei uns
auch im wirtschaftsgeschehen auch als
investoren das konjunkturpaket des
bundes sieht ja vor dass
gewerbesteuerausfälle auch kompensiert
werden zum teil kompensiert werden wir
als land werden dies zu finanzieren das
wird notwendig sein so dass die kommunen
hier eine entlastung erfahren
das ist grundsätzlich natürlich jetzt
unser ziel dass wir im zweiten halbjahr
2020 die nachfrage unterstützen durch
gezielte maßnahmen zum einen natürlich
der bund über das konjunkturpaket 130
milliarden euro
das ist eine starke aussage und wir als
land wolle mit einem eigenen landes
konjunkturprogramm noch unterstützen
gezielt gerade in den bereichen der
transformation stichwort digitalisierung
das sehe ich übrigens auch bei der
automobilindustrie eine große chance und
da müssen wir noch besser werden
dieser begriff innovation ist ja immer
sehr schön und viel verwendet ist sagen
wir mal der begriff das was
möglicherweise einen teil der lösung aus
also innovation ist das erfolgsmodell
unsere wirtschaft in baden-württemberg
wir haben eine hohe exportquote von 42
prozent und gerade in der automobilen
zulieferer industrie von oft über 80
prozent das heißt auf den weltmärkten
müssen unsere unternehmen bestehen bei
den rahmenbedingungen die wir hier
glücklicherweise ja auch wahrnehmen
dürfen muss die wirtschaft über
innovation über technologischen
fortschritt im wettbewerb bestehen hier
unterstützen wir auch als land
beispielsweise im bereich künstliche
intelligenz
da haben wir dasselbe valley gemeinsam
mit der wirtschaft ins leben gerufen
wir starten jetzt auch in anderen
bereichen stichwort batterie
zellfertigung ein projekt gemeinsam mit
dem bund wir finanzieren es auch um hier
eigene kompetenz aufzubauen in dem stark
wachsenden markt die herausforderung für
die deutsche autoindustrie war schon vor
der krise der korona krise groß sie ist
traditionsbewusst und stolz die deutsche
autoindustrie aber die lage der
unternehmen zeigt an unseren beispielen
dass es jetzt möglicherweise um die
existenz geht einfache lösungen gibt es
nicht aber eine kapitulation vor der
autokrise darf es auch nicht geben
[Musik]